I I certainly didn't mean to mention
that i I'm I'm not really in front of
large ideas of people and I was
incredibly overwhelming and and I know
Brian will understand how incredibly
nervous and taken aback I was a there's
no way for someone like me to prepare
for something like that so I almost of
the movie to prom so I should have
thanked him and thank you for reminding
me I'm incredibly embarrassed if you'd
please if you have an opportunity
appropriate please quote means am
writing is irresponsible these films I
thank you yes sir yes of course
well I I also have to say another
another major in time I did forget out
of my fear anxiety to assist to say was
to face innovators which was our first
showing and our most important show and
festival is much like I hope you too
much because incredibly the program very
festival and one that was incredibly fit
for us I hope that you know being there
we're in there eight months ago i'll be
here is something i had with idle and
it's a really important festival and
thinking back into our first street
would be where I need to go and talking
about this poem flipper seven people see
the first time to be here now it does
feel like it yes it's something that
you've learned in the last couple of
months that you'd wish you'd learn
months ago or years ago something that I
learned in Alaska buns album to just to
stay patient through your film we've
been handling the theatrical release
ourselves which means I've been taking
the post trip to the printers and
printing it myself and taking it to the
fears and picking it up at the actual
release for last week and stay patient
through that and still loving your film
for that and not trying to begin to
resent it and do your best to because no
matter how much you love your film after
you've seen it a thousand times and
presented q dated a thousand times it's
very easy to get cynical died so I tried
really hard to not be to remind myself I
a year ago I would have never thought to
come here to you before that I would
have never thought to be outside so I
think just keep on reminding myself and
I'm lucky and grateful
yes yes
I I mean I hope it brings the film more
room we're going to be a DVD almost a
month in a day for now so I hope it
brings attention to DVD movies having
said that more than once in with you
actually could release it it's been
incredibly taxing financially and
personally trying to get out there so I
think when it comes to financially
unless someone comes out and puts some
more vested interest in to it or hands
will be tied in terms of a wider
theatrical release but having said that
I think the DVD rosewood you live apart
to us and I hope that this woman some
awareness to it I hope it Maya my
failure to it to acknowledge the most
most important people including Pullman
MP anything my acceptance speech goes it
was understood and not and not possessed
so thank you think about you should
watch for a film on I am only to gaze
away from securing the rights to
everything has been agreed upon but
since it's not signed I can't redo it
yet but his moment dream projects have
been working on trying to get the rights
to it for three years the writer is very
famous not dead some JD Salinger no one
has ever made in the atoms work before
and bet he's very well known and it's
mentoring project and readily humbled to
get to me got me when it happens and I
believe it will have resulted in that so
and now I have money to help which is
another thing i forgot something
accurate this is but i'm cooking i hope
i really really open to have to do any
wet up so you can clear all these thank
you's because I owe a lot of that so
thank you very much one question on of
mush thank you guys very much